Agnes considers herself
one of the first ones here.
Most people think
she's an insufferable snob,
but I understand her
having played her now,
all these months.
♪ (DRAMATIC ORCHESTRAL MUSIC
PLAYING) ♪
There's a big storyline
in the arrival
of the Russell family
who are building a mansion
across the street
from my townhouse.
When my late husband
bought this, it was rural.
Central Park was
just countryside.
She doesn't know the Russells.
She can't stand
what they're about.
It's all manipulation
and ostentation,
and it's everything
that I abhor.
Judging by your aunt's face,
it'll be a while
before you see me here again.
(BOTH CHUCKLING)
CHRISTINE BARANSKI:
I give Marian a hard time.
She's my brother's daughter
and I know
what my brother was like
and it led to his ruin.
You lived or died
by your reputation.
I feel that Agnes
has her best interests in mind.
I really do.
I know more about these things
than you give me credit for.
BARANSKI: My brother was
supposed to manage the estate,
but he squandered it.
I really had to step up
and be the big sister.
Money isn't everything.
You say that to me
after the sacrifice I made
to save your skin.
There is undercurrent
of resentments.
I'm very grateful.
So you should be.
I can see rather quickly
that Peggy is extremely smart.
If you're interested,
I would like to hire you
as my secretary.
That does interest me.
I can see that Peggy's journey
is a lot harder
than my niece's is going to be.
Agnes has had a tough life.
She respects anybody
who still is going to
make something of herself.
Life has taught me one thing,
Ms. Scott.
If you don't want
to be disappointed,
only help those
who help themselves.
That's the woman you see
at the beginning of the series,
is a woman who's just had to
really make it on her own.
I love keying into her
extraordinary strength
and certitude.
Ada is an unmarried lady,
what was called at that time
a spinster, an old maid.
♪ (DELICATE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
She is the sister of Agnes,
who is a wealthy widow,
and she is the aunt of Marian,
who is, much to Ada's delight,
coming to live with
her two aunts in New York City.
This is Miss Marian Brook,
our late brother's daughter.
For Ada, who doesn't have
any children of her own,
here is a chance
to be a mother of sorts.
All we both want
is your happiness.
You may disagree with us,
but that is all we want.
Across the street
are the Russells,
who are the new money,
and their house is amazing,
their carriage is amazing,
their footmen's outfits
are amazing.
It's a palace,
and Mr. and Mrs. Russell are
industrialists and new money
and it's a fight between
the old New York
and new New York.
My mother, your grandmother,
was a Livingston
of Livingston Manor.
They ruled justly
until the new people invaded.
It's not quite
as simple as that.
Yes, it is.
Agnes disapproves
of them greatly.
This is just like the devil
has moved in across the street.
Ada isn't so sure.
She knows she shouldn't be
interested in them,
but she can't help
but creep over to the window
and look out the blinds
as they move into their new home
with all their finery.
AGNES VAN RHIJN: First,
Mrs. Chamberlain and now them.
Why don't we just go outside
and roll in the gutter?
It will save time.
Remember, Agnes,
charity is the order of the day.
Agnes is really afraid
of change,
and Ada is eager for it.
She's at this moment in her life
when things have just been
the same for a really long time,
and there's nothing happening.
And now, things are afoot,
and afoot not just in the world
and just in New York,
but within her own family
and on her own street.
LOUISA JACOBSON: Marian sees
the world as full of brightness.
And what is so cool about Marian
is her strength of character.
♪ (CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
We meet Marian
when she's lost everything.
She's lost her home,
she's lost her father,
she's lost most
of her possessions.
You will have somewhere
in the region of 30 dollars.
JACOBSON:
And she comes to New York.
She's very vulnerable
and doesn't have
any footing anymore,
except for in her aunts,
and she's heard a lot
of bad things about Agnes.
You are my niece.
And you belong to old New York.
Agnes immediately tells her that
she has to come out of mourning.
You will go tomorrow with Ada
to my dressmaker, and no black.
But I'm in mourning.
People here won't know
when Henry died.
That's the first instance where
I really butt heads with her.
AGNES:
She can be so like him at times.
She speaks
and I hear Henry's voice.
Challenging everything,
just as he did.
And look how that turned out.
Well, I like her strong views.
I like her energy.
Ada is more understanding of me.
We also have a bond
over my father.
You told me Aunt Agnes
hated my father because
he sold our family house.
Do you feel the same?
Agnes has always carried
the weight of the world
on her shoulders.
Henry used to tease me
and make me laugh.
So, no...
I don't feel the same way.
Peggy and Marian's relationship
is really interesting.
I hope one day to write a novel.
I envy you.
I'm not like you.
I don't have any burning talent
yearning to be free.
I just want to be busy,
to be needed.
Peggy and Marian's
relationship grows from
a transactional moment
into a more meaningful
relationship where
Marian looks up to Peggy
and is inspired by Peggy.
It ends up growing
into even more than that.
Why don't you look in?
Aunt Agnes would have a fit.
I could wait downstairs to make
sure you can get back in.
My fellow conspirator.
DENÉE BENTON: Something
I think is so interesting
about Peggy's character
is she's the one woman
we kind of get to see
in the professional class.
♪ (CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
There was a newer class that was
developing during that time.
What it meant to not be
in the service industry
or to be
an inherited wealth aristocrat,
but to be a lawyer, a writer,
an architect.
We see these different things.
I do know you've taken a chance
on me, Mrs. van Rhijn.
And I appreciate it.
Life has taught me one thing,
Miss Scott.
If you don't want
to be disappointed,
only help those
who help themselves.
She runs into every kind
of obstacle that you would face
as someone who has the audacity
to dream of being a writer
as a Black woman in that time.
What other changes must I make
to be published?
Your name is fine, but your race
would have to remain concealed.
It's the best arrangement
I can offer.
There are at least two white men
sitting in a bar
around the corner
drinking away their sorrows
because I turned them down.
They'd kill to be
in your position.
But they'd never be
in my position.
We get to see Peggy have
these interesting moments
downstairs in the basement,
when Peggy is with the
service staff of that household.
And you're able to see
the assumption
that is made by all of them
that Peggy must be poor,
Peggy must not have access to
these certain kinds of things.
Have you been working
with Mrs. van Rhijn?
Yes.
I suppose you think that
makes you a sort of secretary.
She is a secretary
and not a "sort of" anything,
which puts her above you
in the pecking order,
Miss Armstrong.
If it were the 1880s,
this would've been my story.
The proximity that I walk today
felt very similar
to the proximity
that she was walking,
and it fell off the page to me.
I know what she's... carrying.
You're a New Yorker now.
We both are.
And for a New Yorker,
anything is possible.
I think one of the most
challenging aspects
of playing Oscar
has been keeping this mustache
exactly the same shape
for over a year.
♪ (CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Oscar has definitely learned
the value
of a good verbal laceration
from his mother.
Stop talking to yourself
and ring the bell.
-I'm going up to change.
-I doubt it, Mama.
I'd say you will come down again
without having changed at all.
In a world where almost everyone
tip toes around Agnes,
terrified of courting
her displeasure,
Oscar is basically
the only character
who is fearless.
I think, fundamentally,
they're very close.
Which is why she endures this.
Agnes views New York
elite society
as a small group of people
with notable genealogy.
And that's the way
she would like it to remain.
Oscar, I think can see this
new money's going to have
a greater influence,
and he wants to be a part
of it.
OSCAR VAN RHIJN:
I think we should know
the Russell family.
I would go further,
and say I think it is mad
that we don't.
Money is of primordial
importance to Oscar.
He is very much on the hunt
for an heiress.
He is independently wealthy,
himself.
He will one day inherit
the whole Brook's household.
But he sees wealth
of a whole new magnitude,
and he has an insatiable hunger
for the lifestyle
that that will support.
I must have more money.
I love all the minutiae
of etiquette
and the behavioral codes.
I've tried to break
as many of those rules
as possible in every scene.
So I play a character
who has a hearty irreverence
for those rules,
especially when he's
in the Brook's household.
I think he's aware that this
kind of charm is a commodity
in polite New York society.
Verbal playfulness
has a kind of currency to it.
Handsome young men who talk
are always useful.
That's what my mother says.
And a girl should always listen
to her mom.
BLAKE RITSON:
Oscar kind of goes through life
considering it a game
where you can make up
your own rules.
This is a world where
most characters are very bound
by social conduct
and the codes of behavior
and it's quite fun
to play a part
who is happy to break
those rules.
He'd much rather be happy
than good.
Tom Raikes is a young,
confident, hardworking attorney
from Doylestown, Pennsylvania.
♪ (UPLIFTING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
THOMAS COCQUEREL:
In episode one, we meet him
and Marian Brook,
and I think at the start
it's a professional relationship
but he quickly becomes
quite charmed by her.
Being put in that position
as her attorney
and trying to help her
financially get back
on her feet,
he's the one who pushes her
to move to New York
to have a safety net
and to be with her aunts.
I'm sorry you're going,
Ms. Brook.
But you're glad
I will be taken care of.
And good luck on your travels.
THOMAS: I was interested to play
a young guy
who is trying to find his way
in a world
that he didn't quite know,
but do it with, you know,
a chin up
and hardworking attitude.
I think there are clear rules
in that society
at that point in time for sure.
He's walking into a world
that has old ways that are set,
and he's not particularly
accepted off the bat.
We only receive the old people
in this house.
Never the new.
He has to work quite hard
to ingratiate himself, I guess,
for lack of a better word,
into that society.
There's a clear difference
between the old money
and the new money.
Not that he comes from either.
I think he comes
from no money, really.
And that's what's
so interesting about him
is that he has a wonderful arc,
really,
starting from humble beginnings,
and through hard work,
he manages to climb that ladder.
New York has plenty to offer
to the new arrival.
But what would I have to offer
New York?
It's just a joy to come to work
and to work on these characters
and in this world.
There's so much depth
to everything.
MARIAN BROOK:
I wish I understood
what brings you to New York.
Simple. I want to be here.
-And that's enough of a reason?
-Of course it is!
When I see what I really want,
I take it if I can.
SIMON:
One of the interesting aspects,
I think, of households,
were the armies of servants.
You had to rely
on their discretion,
and I think Bannister
rather prides himself
on his discretion.
♪ (ORCHESTRAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Welcome to East 61st Street,
Ms. Marian.
My name is Bannister,
Mrs. van Rhijn's butler.
Bannister, the butler, is
the backbone of the Brook house,
which is owned
by Mrs. van Rhijn
and her sister Ada.
Mrs. van Rhijn makes it
quite clear
who is the boss of the house,
and I'm in command of the staff.
I wonder if they'll try
to set him up with Ms. Marian.
He wants an heiress,
the richest he can find,
and Ms. Marian
hasn't a penny to her name.
If you've finished
demolishing the characters
of every member of this family,
John and I will serve luncheon.
We have a very compact staff,
I think.
Somehow, we keep the house
running very efficiently,
thanks to my steady gaze.
(BELL RINGS)
Come on, John. Look lively.
I think perhaps
he has a self-image
of being the general authority
senior figure of the staff.
I think his natural
Britishness makes him
come across occasionally
as rather cold and chilly,
but that helps
with his authority.
I don't want trouble
in the house,
and while she may not want
to cause it,
she may be the cause of it.
I repeat. It is not for us
to have an opinion.
Certainly, not that one.
What I found very extraordinary
is the people with money
how uncomfortable their lives
nonetheless were
from the way they dressed,
from the formality
of their behavior,
the extraordinary social rituals
they had to endure.
It was routine.
That was how it was done.
(GROANS, CHUCKLES)
Does seem terrible chore.